have you ever looked at your concurrency
code and wondered if everything was
somehow wrong
everything
if you have then by the end of this talk
I'm hoping that I can convince you that
we have a solution and if you haven't
then by the end of this talk I'm hoping
that I can at least convince you that
something is very wrong with the way
that we write concurrent code in Scala
today
my name is Jetta jashinsa and I'm a
software developer at Morgan Stanley for
the last six years I've worked as part
of a team that has built a platform that
can automatically parallelize user code
our platform is built on top of Scala
and our clients write their applications
on top of our platform
these clients check in their code to our
code base and over the last decade this
has grown into one of the biggest
scholar code bases in the world at over
12 million lines of scalar code
we have about a thousand developers
globally checking in code to this code
base and of those thousand developers
only about 100 are developers who like
me only work on the core platform itself
the goal of the platform is to provide a
framework that truly separates business
logic from execution concerns
so today I'm going to show you how we do
that but before I do that I'd like to
talk to you a bit about the current
solutions that are available for
concurrency and Scala today
so let's start by defining a monad
um as all of you will presumably know
and monad is like a container or a
wrapper that abstracts away execution
concerns
so in theory we love monads because they
do exactly what we're trying to do they
try to abstract away execution
and because we're talking about
concurrency today I'm going to focus on
Futures there are a whole bunch of
different types of monads but a future
wraps up some slow computation
dispatches it to another thread and then
it returns immediately and it allows us
to write asynchronous and non-blocking
code
um so in theory we love Futures and we
love monads
um but they invade our type system and
this is why they don't quite fit the
bill when it comes to concurrency
okay let's take a look at some code
please pay attention because I'm going
to keep coming back to this code over
the presentation
so let's say you've just started your
new role some newspaper website and your
boss asks you to write a piece of code
that will tell us some metrics about
visits to your page
and for that you're going to need a few
pieces of data so online uh two there
we're just going to get the raw hit
count this is simply number of visits to
the page on line three we're gonna get a
Google account this is the number of
visits to the page that came through
Google searches
and online four we're going to get the
the real hits
um so this is the one that actually
matters these are people who came onto
the page and actually spent some time
reading the article
so we're going to pass these three
pieces of data to this normalized
function it's going to await them
appropriately and it's going to return
as some metrics object
so this is the code you want to write to
solve the problem that you've been given
to solve it's clear and concise and easy
to reason about and debug it's written
in a declarative and functional style
it's expressive it's a description of
the problem that you're trying to solve
and not how you're trying to solve it
um more than that we've achieved
encapsulation because our type signature
just Returns the metrics object doesn't
leak implementation detail and similarly
we don't rely on knowing the
implementation detail of these views
methods
so job done right well no code like this
in any real application is not going to
fly and that's because we've got these
three sequential blocking calls
presumably to a data store all these
views methods could just be CPU bound
methods
um we've written this sequentially so
what that means if we do have a data
store that we're we're querying we've
got three round trips to that data store
um so this very quickly becomes the
bottleneck in any real application
so okay at this point
um any scholar developer might look at
the options available to them for
achieving concurrency and they might
decide on futures
so a future we can wrap these views
methods that are doing the i o in the
future
and so then we'll need to get at the
underlying value that they represent
um so let's say we make that change
now remember the views methods return
Futures so we need a way to get at the
underlying data these raw values that we
need
Scala provides a syntax sugar to do that
there's this four comprehension which
lets you get at the underlying data
there on lines three four and five and
then there's a yield keyword that lets
you pass them into the normalized
function
um so okay we've paid the price of these
two tiny keywords we have lost a bit of
the clarity that we had before because
it's not really that obvious to anyone
but a scholar developer that there's no
Loop here yes there's a four but it's
four comprehension it unwraps these
features so okay now you're thinking
really job done and it's okay this code
is still relatively expressive
um it's it's a description of the
problem I'm trying to solve
but then after some debugging and
testing you realize that actually
there's no concurrency here at all
um and that's because this four
comprehension is just syntax sugar over
a map and Flat map and with Filter so
actually in line four in order to even
construct your Google stats dot views
future you need to wait for the result
of the page stat stop views future to
come back so you've destroyed all hope
of concurrency here you've still written
synchronous and blocking code
and okay obviously this is a solvable
problem
um we can lift up those three variables
to the top of our function and now in an
attempt to name them
um appropriately we've prefixed them
with an F because now they are
representing futures of these metrics
that we wanted to get back
and then we can pass them into our four
comprehension get the underlying data in
line 7 8 and 9. and then pass that
finally to the normalized function
so okay we've achieved concurrency now
we do have concurrency these Futures
will be created the execution context
will handle
executing them and maybe now job done
except that to get to this point where
the code runs how we want it to run
we've doubled the size of the code let's
take a look at what we started with this
was six lines
this is 13 but more than that we've lost
the clarity that we had and if somebody
else comes along and tries to refactor
by pulling uh lines two three and four
and just inlining them into line seven
eight and nine they've again destroyed
any hope that you had a concurrency
um so because these Futures have invaded
our type system we're forced to do these
kind of tie back robatics and Wrangle
with the code to get it to run the way
that we want it to run and this is
before we've even done anything at all
more sophisticated that we might want
our system to do like cache the queries
to the data store
um or batch them or even run on another
jvm as part of a distributed system
so
um you may think this is a fabricated
example but actually this was taken from
open source code on the Guardians GitHub
and actually the the developers there
did a really brilliant job of keeping
some of the clarity that they presumably
started with when they wrote this code
um you can see the parallels there with
the example they've had to lift these
Futures to the top of their function and
then use the fork on branch and to get
at the underlying data
so developers really are having to do
this and it's because execution concern
has leaked into their type system
um a picture speaks a thousand words so
this is something that my boss's
children put together for me um It's A
reproduction of a classic and it some
sums up how developers are left feeling
when they are being forced to write code
like this because remember back on like
day one we solved the business problem
that we were asked to solve and since
then all of the changes that we've been
making have been to force it to run in
the way that we want it to run
um okay I'm still seeing some
unconvinced faces so maybe I'm just
being melodramatic and life is not fair
we don't always get to write the code
that we want to write
um
because you know everything is sorted
right we have concurrency that we wanted
to have and we're done
um but let's take a look again at our
function signature here
um normalized metrics take some article
ID and it returns metrics and that's the
crucial point the fact that this returns
a metrics mean that our function is
still a blocking function any call to
our function has to block and wait for
this metric object
so this doesn't provide parallelism over
many Halls if I have a bunch of articles
that some author has written and I map
my function over those inputs we're
going to block and wait for a metrics
result at every iteration of that Loop
so okay my function it's self-contained
concurrency but it doesn't it is not
current function we can't scale up
and other problems exist if you've
programmed with asynchronous programming
Frameworks you will know that stack
Trace is now no longer look like the
code that we wrote the jvm stacks don't
map to the code that we actually wrote
so it becomes harder to reason about
um there are all sorts of invasive types
now that are not just your basic types
so if you get a compiler error it's like
an essay of types that you're reading to
deduce what's going on
debuggability becomes harder because
where do you even put the break point
when you don't know when anything is
actually running and composability which
I will come back to but essentially if
my function now is returning a future of
metrics rather than just a metrics then
anything that calls it is going to have
to deal with that it's not dealing with
the underlying metrics type that
represents our business logic
so maybe now I'm convincing you a bit
more really developers are frustrated
and rightly so by having to write code
that looks like this
um but okay maybe we're still being
melodramatic because you could argue
let's just async everything we've you
know got to grips and Futures now so we
can wrap our whole function in the
future and now we can return a future of
a metrics object
so that's all well and good now calls to
this function will no longer block but
let's say again that we have a bunch of
inputs and we want to map our function
over those inputs
um the caller of that would like to get
back a sequence of metrics but what
they're actually getting back is a
sequence of Futures of metrics
so okay in the very best case maybe they
wanted to get back a future of a
sequence of metrics so then they can
just unwrap and get the underlying data
but it's going to take you some time on
stack Overflow to figure out that yes
Scala has an API to do that
futures.sequence API you can do that
conversion then going back the other way
is going to take you a bit more time and
stack Overflow so you're already even in
this very very simple example you're
already doing type acrobatics to convert
between these types because Futures have
now invaded your type system
and a future where the only monad in the
world and all things were Futures then
this might work
but future is not the only mode act so
how do these things now compose how do
we convert from one to another let's say
that your boss now introduces a
requirement to implement a cancelable
future
um it's not a crazy requirement
um maybe once you've kicked off a query
you want to be able to cancel it if you
no longer need the result free up
machine resources
so now you've got this cancelable future
which is in your type system but how
does that play with regular futures
um can we assign one to the other we're
now having to write converters between
these things from what was a seemingly
simple requirement and some developer on
your team is going to have to figure
this out
um and let's say that we wanted to deal
with failure cases as well so let's say
that rather than a metric we want to
return a try of a metric
um but we're making it asynchronous so
it's a future of a try over metric so
some caller that's passing multiple
inputs and mapping our function over
them is going to get a
sequence of Futures of tries of metrics
and they're going to want to convert
that to a future of sequence
of tries of metrics have I got that
right is everyone still with me if
you're not I don't blame you um because
this is now an uncomfortable number of
square brackets and doing the type
acrobatics to convert between those
types is
just not the problem I want to solve to
clarify the problem I wanted to solve I
did solve back on like slide three in
six lines of code so why am I spending
this mental energy solving these like
type gymnastic problems um when I could
be solving more business problems and
moving on with my life
um and this this problem has given rise
to the use of something in Scala called
free monads um this is something that
people who are very good at category
Theory and quite frankly people who are
a lot smarter than me have proposed this
as a solution so these try to push all
execution concerns to the edges of the
program so we build up these huge data
structures and we chain together our
function calls and nothing actually runs
until we have an interpreter that we
Define for this and similar story with
applicatives with effects which tries to
do something similar to try and cope
with execution concerns in a functional
way
but our code base like I said is 12
million lines of code and growing all
the time we have a thousand developers
checking in code to that code base a lot
of them are coming from java backgrounds
a lot of them are strapped they're
writing the algorithms that you know
calculate risk on these Financial
products they don't want to be using
free monads or applicatives with effects
you don't get to a code base of 12
million lines of code if you're forcing
people to write code like that all the
alternative is you hire people with phds
but we're struggling to hire people as
it is
um and there's another indication that
something is very wrong and that's that
we have ended up with all these
different types of libraries and apis
that essentially try and do the same
thing they're trying to Grapple with
this same problem
um and we reckon that if scholar
developers were satisfied with the
solution that had been presented to them
then they wouldn't be wasting their time
writing other tasks and fibers and other
types of monads they would be solving
the business problems in front of them
um
so really I hope that you're agreeing
with me somewhat now that developers are
left feeling like this
um this is not the problem that I wanted
to solve this was not what I signed up
for I solved the problem back on day one
and now my boss is still asking me why
my PR is still in progress
okay so in an era where everything is
multi-core why is functional programming
not winning
it has some really really great features
that make it extremely desirable in a
multi-threaded environment immutability
for one if you're guaranteed everything
is immutable you're no longer worrying
about mutable State and thread safety
and everything becomes way easier to
reason about
referential transparency if so a
function is referentially transparent if
it's guaranteed to give back the same
result every time we give it the same
input so given the same input gives you
the same output and that is guaranteed
no matter how or where or when it runs
and this immediately gives us a number
of really nice side effects we can
reorder calls to these functions because
it doesn't matter if we do it first or
last we're going to get the same result
we can that lends itself to running in
parallel or asynchronously doesn't
matter if I block and wait for a result
to a referentially transparent function
or if I run it in an asynchronous way
and register a call back and get the
result and it's ready
that result is guaranteed to be the same
it gives us portability which means that
in a distributed system I can run this
exact same function on any machine in my
grid of machines it's going to be the
same result and because of that I can
cache that result I don't need to do any
CPU execution at all as long as I have
some way to reference this call with
this given input um and then get it back
out of the cache
so referential transparency remember
this one because I'll come back to this
one
um Purity again it functions are pure
they have no side effects they are very
easy to read about so it just becomes
easier to program composability we want
to be able to compose our functions we
want to you know build up these bigger
functions out of reusable components
and we want to be able to map our higher
order functions over multiple inputs
so what's not to like why is it that in
most indexes that you look at that
measure how widely used a programming
language is
why is it that functional programming
languages don't really come out on top
and in fact there is one that
consistently does come in the top ten
can anyone take guess what it is
definitely not Haskell
uh JavaScript does come in some of them
uh I don't think anyone said it yet I'll
come back I'll come back and do the
reveal later
um but we think the reason functional
programming is not doing as well is
because it's not the code that you want
to write
so the situation that we kind of have
ended up with Scala today
um is kind of this
burning platform so people are trying to
write their scholar code they're trying
to ignore the problem the burning
problem that is concurrency and again
thanks to my boss's children
um I have this representation
um and we think that this is a bit like
sitting in a burning room trying to have
a nice cup of tea but really you're
getting a bit hot under the collar and
it's just not a comfortable way to drink
your tea and I would know that because I
am British
um and these terrorists have provided a
solution to scholar developers they've
provided these free monads and these
objectives of the facts but the solution
that they have provided is really like
giving somebody this huge bulky fire
suit and telling them to go back into
the burning building yes you can go back
in and yes you can maybe pick up your
cup of tea and drink it but you're
wearing these clunky monadic gloves and
you've got this huge mask on your head
that you can't really see or breathe out
of so yes you can solve the problem but
you feel like a klutz nobody wants that
when they're coding
um so there's been this movement to kind
of go back to basics
um with Scala but to ask to go back to
basics is like asking to go back into
this Burning room
um without any protection at all
um
and then there's on the other like The
Other Extreme
um there's these category theorists that
are pushing these Solutions but the
solutions they are pushing on us require
phds to understand
um and there's seemingly no middle
ground
but is there a third way well at this
point I'm going to ask you to make a
choice time for a question
um red pill or blue pill I have a
volunteer who is going to help me hand
out these pills please
make a choice
um if you have heard all that you want
to hear and you kind of want to forget
what you heard
um even if you want to walk out of the
room I will not be insulted you can take
a blue pill
and go back to coding as you always have
known it
however if I've convinced you that there
really is a problem
um and if you want to hear my solution
then take a red pill and you'll see what
I have to propose please don't take any
pill if you're allergic to anything
that's in chocolate and or if you don't
want to take the pill
um it won't really affect your enjoyment
of the rest of this but the Sugar Rush
might actually be nice
Okay so
while the chocolate is going around let
me ask you for a moment to forget
everything that you know about how we
program in garbage collected languages
so let's imagine that somebody comes
along and they give us a garbage
collector except that it's not wrapped
up in the language this is a type
intrusive garbage collector which means
that we're going to have direct access
to the garbage collector internals so
let's see what what happens now when I
try and allocate new metrics object
well I'm not going to get back a metrics
object I'm going to get back an edem
pointer to that metrics object because
this object was created in Eden
and obviously then we're going to need
some sort of conversion if we wanted to
assign a which was an either pointer to
B which has a type of gen 1 pointer so
okay maybe we can write those converters
to do that that's probably not
impossible
um and we might imagine some apis from
GC API that takes a sequence of some of
these pointers and tells you whether
they're live or not
um
but now let's introduce a raise so
you've got to allocate the array so
there's an Eden pointer and it's a
pointer to a sequence of metrics except
that those metrics are all also Eden
pointers to metrics
um so really what I've got here is a
sequence of metrics but what I've ended
up having to parse is these four types
to get there
um this get to us because obviously we
now have these gem one pointers and
we've got like gen one of sequence of
gen 1 of C of metrics
um and now let's say array 3 is actually
of type gen 1 of array of gen 1 pointer
of uh metric
um if anyone here can you know write the
few lines of code that it takes to
convert between these things I applaud
you I definitely cannot
um so hopefully you can see the
parallels that I'm trying to draw with
Futures we very very quickly even in the
most basic case end up with these type
acrobatics that we're being forced to do
and nobody wants to write code like this
if we had been given a garbage collector
that was like this like nobody nobody
would want to use that there would be
developer Rebellion this is definitely
not the code that you want to write and
there's a really good blog called what
color is your function and essentially
it makes the same case that we've ended
up with something akin to this for
futures
so this is the lithograph edition of the
picture
um we really are feeling frustrated at
the situation that we have ended up with
with concurrent code and Scala
um okay so let's take a look at the
programming languages and the the
runtimes that are available today and
let me ask you another question does C
plus plus take care of memory management
would anyone here argue that it does
no but we do have Primitives in the
language itself to allocate and free
memory
um so does that mean that c plus takes
care of memory management
no it doesn't it means that we can build
very sophisticated things like manage
pointers that kind of try to do that for
us but it doesn't mean that the language
itself is taking care of concurrency
so of memory management sorry
um so another question does the jvm then
take care of concurrency
definitely not but we do have these
Primitives we've got notifying weight
and volatile and synchronized and all
the rest
um and yes we can build very complicated
things on top of that to try and have a
concurrency but the jvm itself is not
taking care of concurrency much like C
plus is not taking care of memory
management just because it's given us
these Primitives in the language
so does anything solve for concurrency
does anyone want to have another guess
at the language that I mentioned before
the functional language that comes up is
very widely used
not well no no
everyone recognize it yeah so yeah
sequel
um
so you may not like it but SQL is a
functional language it doesn't so much
have a type system
um but this query here all I'm saying is
give me all the customers who have
loyalty points greater than ten thousand
um and it's a declarative statement of
the problem that I'm trying to solve at
no point here am I writing a mechanical
description of how I want the database
execution engine to take this query
break it up parallelize it deal with
concurrency and locking of reads and
rights to the data store and then give
me back the correct answer
um and if somebody on that database
execution engine team makes a
performance Improvement to their
algorithms and their underlying
concurrency I get a performance benefit
to my query without having to change a
single line of code
so yes SQL solves for concurrency and we
think this is one of the reasons that
it's proven so durable as a functional
programming language this is the code
that people are writing and want to
write
okay
um
the question really that I am asking you
to think about is what is the runtime
because really when we're programming in
just about anything we have a runtime
um even in in assembly
um you're you're kind of your CPUs
modern CPUs are no longer just executing
one instruction per cycle they can
execute multiple instructions per cycle
and they're doing very sophisticated
things to run your assembly code so this
is kind of a runtime
um but moving kind of further up the
stack than that when we invented
functions and call Stacks then to make a
function call you're pushing things onto
the call stack and you're changing the
address of the function pointer and I
say you're doing that but really it's
the runtime that's doing those things
for you
um so again this this function call this
call stack this constitutes a runtime
then moving further up the stack and
further forward in the timeline of
computing operating systems come along
and operating systems give you a whole
lot more memory protection being one of
them you can no longer write code that
messes with memory
um in some weird way and then brings
down your entire operating system and
yes you've now given up the freedom to
access and manipulate that directly
addressable memory but I would argue
that most of us don't want or need that
freedom and most of us would rather take
that trade-off and gain back the
protection that we get from the
operating system
and then similarly when the jvm came
along or just managed execution in
general we got um garbage collectors but
now we lost the ability to directly be
allocating and freeing our memory
um but again for most developers that
trade-off is worth it because the
benefit in terms of developer
productivity is huge when you can write
your code and not have to reason about
when an object that you allocated will
be freed and whether this is now a
memory leak
um so much like all the rest of
computing uh this really is all about
trade-offs and as you hand over stuff to
the runtime you maybe give up some
freedoms the runtime can give you a lot
back
um so let's go back to the code that we
started with this normalized metrics
function
um
what would we want the runtime to do
here
if the runtime were smarter we would
want it to take these three calls
presumably their data store calls and we
would want it to batch them and send
them off to the data store in one query
rather than three
or equally if these are just CPU bound
functions we would want to make use of
all the CPUs on our machine and maximize
our CPU usage so we would want the
runtime to run them in parallel and we
know that it's safe to do that because
we know that these are independent calls
um but the runtime can't know that run
times today do not know that
um so we just can't write this code
that's as simple as this and then let
the runtime do that
but I wouldn't be here today if there
wasn't a runtime that could do this our
runtime can
so let me introduce the node
at node this is an annotation that we
have added to the Scala language
um
putting at node on a function is a
guarantee of the referential
transparency of that function so if I as
a developer write my function I can code
RT it takes some input parameter P has a
return type event
um if I stick out node on there then I
am guaranteeing to the runtime that this
is a referentially transparent function
and what that means is that the runtime
can now do all the magic that I
described before because of this
guarantee of referential transparency
notice that the return type of this is
still an INT but what actually happens
is that at compile time our compiler
plugin kicks in
um and it transforms this code using
something called Scala async into an
asynchronous representation of that code
in this case a state machine
so at compile time we end up generating
tons and tons of these State machines
and at runtime we have a scheduler that
knows how to run them that knows how to
run them concurrently that can look for
data store queries and put them in a
batch
but the developer all the developer sees
is these extra five characters
and one thing about referential
transparency is that it turns out to be
really like people gluing together bits
of other referentially transparent
functions and so it becomes quite hard
in an environment like this to actually
write code that's not referentially
transparent with and we were worried at
the very beginning that we were asking
too much of our devs and that um you
know it would be hard for them to
actually get this right and we built a
tool that could check that your code
actually was referentially transparent
but we've never really needed it because
no like material problem has ever been
caused by some developer not
understanding how to write a
referentially transparent function or
marking an app node where it shouldn't
have been on that node
um okay at this point I'm going to show
you how it works so that you don't need
to take my word for it so here's the
code that we started with
um take a look at that while I write a
little launcher for it so
this is the point where hopefully
Internet won't cut out
um
so I'm just going to write this Optimus
app if you've done any Scala before
you'll know that an app is just like
something that has a main method
we have an Optimus app and it's going to
prompt me to override the run method
okay
um so run is the entry point into our
Optimus execution yep
yes I can sorry about that
is that better
great
um so I'm just going to stick an
annotation on here
um this tells the runtime that we are
entering
um graph threads this is our managed
execution
so all I'm going to do is create this
class the metrics reporter
um
some of you may have noticed that I've
got entity on there this is an addition
again that we've added that lets us take
control of class class identity but
creating one of these metric reporters
is a bit like using a Scala apply method
on a Case class
um and now I've got a log somewhere so
let's just say log.info
metrics and then stick the
normalized metrics in there
and let's see how that runs
so the only change actually that is
different between this and my slides is
that now I have that node on here
so at compile time now we're generating
a state machine representation of this
method let me make this bigger too
um okay and we're going to make an
initial kind of session establishment
call to the data store
sorry not responding right now okay
um but then what we're gonna do let me
just scroll
a
bit
oh okay I think that's that's good
enough
um
sorry it's a bit laggy
okay let me Zoom back out
can everyone see essentially this line
and this line
so what we've done without me having to
make a single change except to add that
node to this code that I wanted to write
right at the beginning
we the runtime has batched together
these three calls to the data store and
it's made one query to the data store
and come back and given us that and if
you've done any work on data storage
you'll know that data storage loves
batching often often the performance is
the same as it would be with like a
single query
so we didn't have to do anything our
function still returns a metrics object
so it's still easy to write code that
uses this so let's see now how it scales
up so let's write the slightly more
complicated example let's say I'm going
to get an author out of my author
database
let's get the author that represents me
this is just some overload that takes
primary key and then for each article
in every article that the author has
written
we're going to use something called the
detailed metric reporter the only real
difference is that it takes the article
ID
um
and we're going to ask it to give up its
metrics so for every article that I have
written we are going to call this
metrics you'll see that our ID can
detect the node calls that's very tiny
writing there but it says node call
detected which means that metrics itself
has been annotated as a node so let's
see now how this slightly bigger example
runs
um and what's going to happen here is
that again at compile time for every app
node we have generated a state machine
representation of that piece of code
which lets us then a runtime run it
asynchronously so while our runtime is
off making a database call
um the the scheduler keeps the CPU busy
and it creates these batches that are
then ready to run for when that call
comes back so you'll see now this this
is the first time like there was no
batching magic we could have done here
to get the author but then when we're
getting back all of these stats our
batches are like in the hundreds in this
example and that's without me having to
change a single piece of code that I've
written I still write the code that I
want to write and I can scale it up you
know I can map over this whole bunch of
Articles turns out I've written many
more articles so if the internet holds
out let me just show you one more thing
so let's say I got the author
um
author
actually put that there
um let's say that I go to the database
again and I get the author again
and then let's just log again
uh got author again
okay
so let's see how this one runs
thank you
uh if it runs
okay give it a moment but remember the
first time that we make this call
um
we're gonna have to make a data store
call obviously there is no batching we
can do here we're just trying to get one
author
but then we we log this message that we
got it but look what happens a second
time the second time you don't see any
of this data store related logging
and that is because I now have this
result of this query in cash
and that's because we've made our reads
to the data store referentially
transparent um somebody gave a workshop
yesterday on bi-temporal data stores
which are append only that is
conceptually what we have too so we have
a very cheap way of having a fixed point
in time and if we're querying the
database at that fixed point in time
then the result that we get back is
guaranteed to be the same so obviously
data can change over time but at that
fixed Point our result is guaranteed to
be the same so given that we have these
referentially transparent calls to the
data store now we can cache them so
that's what happens here that's why we
don't get the whole like bunch of
logging there that you see
okay I'm glad the demo worked so let's
continue I am almost done
um so the thing about the node is it is
a monad you can put it in a running
State you can kick it off you can you
know make it ready to run you can ask
for its result you can query whether it
has a result you can query if it has an
error
um
we have cancellation for our nodes we
have a very functional way to do
mutation and to allow change in a
functional environment
exception handling and like side
channels into the nodes so at node is a
node but it's not in the type system and
that goes back to the title of my talk
we do love monads we just do not want
them invading our type system and
forcing us to do these type acrobatics
um
okay gonna end on a quote and then leave
a few times a few minutes of questions
when I used to look out at this world
all I could see was its edges its
boundaries its rules and controls its
leaders and laws
but now I see another world a different
world where all things are possible I
hope that everyone got the Matrix
references otherwise this is just silly
thank you we have a few minutes for
questions and if not I'll be outside
later
yeah go ahead
that's a great question so the question
is what do stack traces look like um my
colleague o'had is working on that at
the moment
um we do have we can keep track of who
incured a node in the state machine so
it is heavier to keep track of that link
but we can enable it in debugging so we
have reconstituted stack traces that let
us actually line up the stack Trace with
your business logic control flow but
yeah without that extra like debugging
we have the same problem as any other
asynchronous framework great question
[Music]
in production we don't we're trying to
enable at least like async profiler in
production and to match up our jvm
frames with what we know about our node
frames
um but no not yet in production
another question over here somewhere
yeah
the very simple one
this one
oh yeah sure
normalized metrics yep
that is a great question I'm not going
to repeat all of it but essentially it
is can the runtime get smarter so if
you're introducing code dependencies
actually into your code like if my views
method actually needed the result of the
raw method can I still be smart about
kicking them off in parallel
um in a limited way yes we do try to
pull up as many of the independent note
calls as we can to the very beginning
and make them as early as possible
um we also have profiling tooling that
can tell us where you've introduced a
concurrency bottleneck like that because
you've got a code dependency so the
tooling you know it doesn't automate it
it tells the developer how to go and fix
their problems so that they get better
concurrency that's step one step two
which is hopefully coming once we have
Loom which is jvm's own like lightweight
threading model step two will be to then
feed back this information that we
learned from the profiler in order to
inform our scheduling algorithms
um but really great question in limited
ways yes you will see that we do
reordering and asynchronous execution uh
but I'm not that much smarter go ahead
that's excellent
really great question uh short answer is
no you can't so the question was how
deeply do we need to
um propagate these at node annotations
when we've got deeply nested function
calls
um we have a problem today where so all
the other systems that I've shown you
the like you know fibers and tasks and
all the rest when something invades your
type system you are forced to compose
the types so you couldn't call a method
that is returning a future of a metric
if you're just expecting a metric
um we made that realization Too Late by
which point this problem had
proliferated so ours does not invade
your type system which means that we can
have a case where a node calls something
that's just a plain death and that then
calls another node but if you had these
types then what you would have is like
future of a thing just the thing calling
future of the thing
um your compiler would actually just not
compile and now we've translated that
into a compiler warning but it does
introduce a concurrency bottleneck
because although you've got asynchronous
then synchronous then async now your
blocking point is the synchronous call
so everything beyond that you've now
serialized that thread and this is
terrible for performance if the
asynchronous thing on the end is a call
to the data store for example because
now we are just waiting for that we we
can't free up the thread to do what we
want it to do which is maximize if you
use while we're off doing IO
um again Loom is hopefully going to be
our solution so obviously one solution
is we do warn about this um we have all
of the compiler warnings
um we have a way to upgrade them to
errors for people that do
um clean up their code
um so people can go in and fix the code
but really the automated way is when we
have these lightweight threads in the
jvm itself we can spin up a thread and
dispatch it or we can spin up like a
fiber or whatever they're calling it
um great question thank you yep
[Applause]
yes we do um I don't have time because
I'm out of time to show you but you come
find me afterwards and I'll show it to
you um yeah we do um yeah quickly
this I really stops in the greater World
getting there we are trying to open
source we really shot ourselves in the
foot by calling it Optimus Prime you'll
notice this package name Hasbro does not
like this so we're doing things like
renames
um obviously we're not releasing any
proprietary code that is built on top of
the platform but we are releasing the
platform code itself some code is
already on GitHub
um I'll try and find a link later and
somehow get it out
um but yes we're in the process of doing
it our end goal is that this will will
be able to spin up Cloud containers that
just have everything you need in order
to run these Optimus runtimes
um but yeah we're heading that way
thanks yes
the last slide we hinted a little bit
about
it yeah
how do you
when you do it with other Monet
Ary
you mean by forcing people to think
about things in their type system
yes like it's oftentimes you do
something through a collection of things
yeah
do not think about things
right
yeah
yes
we do for the very common monouns so for
options and for tries like you mentioned
and for some others we do have node try
um and we have the auto async version of
an option
um so we do try to do that for most
monads generally it depends if somebody
is asking for it we try to make sure
that we have that I'm noticing other
people coming to the room but I will be
outside and around my name is Jetta
thank you again for listening thank you